welcome to the puzzlers paradise with
with me remastered Irish church so let's
see after until some people show up in
the chat and here we're gonna be solving
puzzles for next hour or something like
that so here is the first puzzle I'll be
guys can see it
seeing you live on Twitch
you just check the obviously Amy says
like YouTube or something Oh
I'm supposed to be on Twitch alright
alright five yours good how welcome guys
so it's puzzle of puzzlers paradise so
here's the first position and black is
to play and if you guys have suggestions
feel free to stay serene chat
we'll go from the simpler ones to more
and more advanced but this is plus a
pretty simple I think position
so black is to play
it's black to play hello rational
function test it's black to play and
[Music]
black to play any win basically like
some material
whenever it's like the board is flipped
it means the one
yeah kinetics before I be quintics
before and on c5 Hank say that's good
good job it's pretty simple just want to
start with easier ones so I'm gonna put
some put the next position right now let
me just get ya til on night X before it
takes before Queen takes before it's a
solution I'll move it here nitrix before
takes Queen takes before and let's say
King f1 and rook takes e5 for instance
is just just winning for for black so
this is this is the solution and so
let's put another position
so clear report again will be not so
difficult but like you know me to start
somewhere
like this
yep okay white blame
all right so this is the position it is
right now why to play
hi Kolya girl
so it is white to play right now it's
very nice tactical idea quite typical
but like you know first puzzles would be
easier
yeah 95 that says your guys are so good
maybe I should start giving like some
more difficult stuff 95 Mitchell takes
p7 and that's it 95 tags we should take
B 7 wins on the spot good alright so
let's do something more challenging
because this is very easy for you
[Music]
let's do for instance this one and we
just put new one
Oh
clear port and it is like this king look
it will be little bit more tricky but
like you know slowly getting to more
challenging stuff
and this is black to play obviously
all right black to play let's flip it
mike from red letter media I don't know
who Mike from Rosenberg middle media is
2321 are all right so okay like we've
got 22300 stand well put some more
challenging stuff okay but first
princess this one I'd like to play
and what rotate f6
well yeah Bishop the HVAC yeah okay
Kingston got it good no this is too easy
for you guys so I didn't know what to
expect because the first time doing it
but like right now as I see it I have to
put some real challenging stuff here
because some recent prayers in the chat
so let's yeah this is this sorry engage
seven obviously this is it
like Wayne's and let's put something
else this time to be more challenging
for instance I think I have to grow
really really challenging like because
respect section for easier ones
okay this could be a little bit more
difficult still fairly easy but if you
guys see it like in five seconds again
then definitely I'm going to like you
know harder ones
all right black to play
Oh
yeah black to play
yeah okay this is this is so easy for
you guys no way I'm gonna keep doing
this
yeah you guys are right queen h3 and
mate good let's do something let's do
this one
maybe this will be live with more
challenging 2424 free route 21 only 224
kingi one here
ugh queen 597 overwrite white to move
okay white to move
start looking meantime for the more more
challenging ones because they are guys
so strong
what happens here
follow me how public thank you for
greetings from Poland we shall be seven
what about bishop Eastern Luke Texas
seven come on guys Bishop da de
obviously ya bish of da that's it yeah
that's basically it oh that was weird
it should be shrinking should as far as
I know quintic g8 is not possible anyway
let's go with the next puzzle
next one will be this
kingi one
let's see how quickly you guys can seed
this one
rooks 40 frames six
all right a what to play
yeah Queen J the principal make it much
easier yeah
can guys solve this one as quickly as
previous ones
yam you can good yep that's true queen
g6 okay I have to go even harder I guess
g8 and either Bishop disease or EHD g6
mate damn very good
[Music]
all right let's do them this one to
clear board it'll be King on G okay
pawns here be 75 King g8 roofs
be 5c for a freebie I apologize that
some of the puzzles are giving our
easier like or like very easy for some
of you guys but just don't know who's in
the audience that's why I'm kind of like
trying to gauge by you know giving you
know at first easier puzzles and then
like slowly going to level up so this is
the position black to play
blind for puzzles slow
I know how playing blind for puzzle work
here on the stream
what about this one
g5 and what HTC five
okay so I see I see two of propositions
here either rock taxi tool and g5 or g5
immediately or thirst f5 I don't know
what about that five but like so rooted
c2 or g5 so what do you guys think is
better
all right so I understand who takes d4
and g5 so it's definitely no drop text
g4 and g5 defied the second tell
immediately because just giving up the
exchange for no sort of reason but yeah
the question is whether g5 rook takes c2
because both of them sort of make sense
g5 first this and after HDS g5
okay I'll move it g5 h6g firing what now
yeah h4 yeah that that's it basically
age for it just wins does that decibel
as their idea but what we shop f6 here
I mean honestly this is already doesn't
really matter because to be honest
anything is just very good for for for
black it's just kind of like there was
it was a game between Benjamin buggin
out of stuff early and it was a stage
four in the game Bishop takes take
position just winning yeah and here just
rupees six was winning for instance this
isn't like you know puzzle position so
just kind of like this make sense to you
know give give it to solve but rupees is
just winning so yeah but the main idea
was to find g5 immediately because if
takes role because if takes on c2 and
this g5 then suddenly King the two I
think if I'm right because the robe is
trapped on b5 does the big point
yeah like we can take on g4 h for
Ballentine just comes to the Kings
Island like I'm not sure whether it's
winning for instance so okay so it's
just one of the positions but yes but
anyway do it was good if I was the most
important thing I want you two guys to
find and right now I will put position
from game of Hikaru Nakamura from
Gibraltar 2016 3 Bishop f1 g1 who's
talking she came in g1 points a for
business 65 5 to 7 age 7 Bishop f7 rook
F 898 King h8 to 1825 and it is white to
play and I would like you guys to give
the entire line not just the first move
but like the entire line in the common
in the injured hello Aditya
so I would like you guys to say the
entire line not just
first move because it seems like to me
is pretty obvious the first move
okay I I see with that you know II six
and reading visual is the idea but like
I would ask you guys to say the entire
line would look as blacks defense and so
on because it's not like so obvious
all right that's the thing is six and
what was it blacks defense
each 696 Queen f5 queen of five is not a
move but what attila said in six Knight
takes c6 Bishop g7 King takes German
assume and Quimby to eat the solution
yes so I'll just show there's a little
bit tricky resolves asking for the
entire line not just like one of six
frames of seven because just you know
that's very natural let's say e six
night xe6
we should take this g7 and right now of
course if kimi GA that we can at least
take take what's wrong with this chest
bass Knight takes e5 visual takes away
just wins and and the thing is that
after visited seven King Day is just
seven Queen B - that's the main point
that was that had to be fun and now
there is no way of stopping the Queen
from you know route 85 just black/white
is waning so yeah that that there's a
solution
yes exactly stanislav Karpov died
exactly the solution in v2 so yeah good
but that's why I asked him for the
entire line because ninety six is the
better defense multiple defenses and we
should take c6 all right so let's go of
next one and which one to put maybe this
one again Hikaru Nakamura
ng 1
we're not pawn g8 obviously you should
hear Nancy - one queen of toots -
position
I think so why to play alright so why to
play here
hi soup ha are they hard well like we
have someone like some people in the
chowder like 22 23 hundreds and like the
other puzzles like are like many of us
but are very very simple for them so I
just don't know which would level of
puzzles should I be giving like that's
why I said like very with very simple
ones and right now like we are going
little bit a little bit
I mean I'm not setting up anything
yeah I guess I can so sorry about that
Maya but this is the position and from
Hikaru's game again is Geoffrey Gronk
and from 2016 US Championships let's see
we are you guys can see this one
rational function test Roxy Juan oh come
on man would I be asking for in in
puzzle you know para puzzlers paradise
for remove like Roxy wand it's not like
puzzle like solution sort of so no ezel
Roxy one
but yeah a Mickey D Knight takes d4 and
if we shall be one the night of five yes
what about night eggs ended then
basically that's game over
well what about I takes d4 C takes d4
Knight takes d4 Bishop d1 visualize be
one-eyed night of five
yes 96 yes what about Knight takes d4 CD
yes exactly signs of Karpov visualize
before if I rob you one yet that that's
the solution
yeah so if you guys don't follow with
the solution I will just quickly show
you on the board night x d4 is the move
if we should be one Knight f5 and if
Queen moves no matter what no matter
where that h6 basically ways so possibly
the best defense visualized f5 I
visualize just winning a coin so it's
just completely in position and if she
takes d4 then Bishop takes d4 d5 and
Bureau q1 hitting distribution on e4 so
if it takes d4 the rook takes e4 just
wins so this is the solution let me put
something else right now but I think we
are getting to a little bit more
complicated stuff so at least your guy
you guys are basically you have to think
about not like it's like five seconds of
solution so that's good and let's do
right now maybe let me choose something
more difficult now this is
yeah let's do this one white to set the
board
white to move so does the position right
to move
from the puzzle chest book if I can put
it like this
I got lots of them
it's like greatest 550 puzzles of like
12 year 2016 51 okay so what do you guys
think about this one
okay it it takes f6 and King takes the
King 66
a terminology you say that we Enzo
bishop before can you say that exactly
the exact line we're talking about
because I'm a little bit confused not
sure if I understand what you mean
all right I think sighs no carp of what
you are saying is what terminal also had
in mind
so basically takes yes
okay this line what about it takes us
asking 36 F takes G 7 rook c8 bishop
before and King e6 and we shall read
King f7 how about that
yes but that's what I'm saying he takes
f6 King D 66 ft x g7 rook c8 we shall be
forking is 6 we should avoid king of 7
to me how public to mohammed theta pata
topic Salada all you guys are saying
this line and this is my response to
this after Bishop before check ago King
e6 we should avoid king f7 and I stopped
the pawn and I presumably even win with
black unless I'm missing something
good for you if you can like make it
work so awful why but like know that I
can see a list
now tough one right isn't it
Rudy five 1985
oh yeah you got it guys but it took some
time
rook before yeah that's the solution
Rock d4 and yeah rock d4 has the
solution rock before so he wasn't so
easy rook takes d4 and now it takes f6
and this is weighing obviously and there
is no way black can do anything here
simply because you know both rocking on
the sea for a night of stasis hanging so
it was tricky I'm glad that finally I
found something that you had like some
fine sample that you at least you were
struggling with here but anyway good
that you found this rock before
yeah exile hitting the rogue and
attacking the knight yeah it was
trickier differ as the really nice move
I think so yeah let's put another one
I'll just show if for people who hadn't
kind of like figure out was from the he
takes f6 I'll just put on the board
either way King takes t6 Texan g7 rook
see it only move we showed before and
many people were suggesting that this is
the winning line because Bishop wood
comes to f8 and basically cuts the rock
out of the eighth-ranked and that's
basically it and here basis and
calculation are the thing that the King
g6 we shove evade and King King after I
catch the palm of my king and I'm left
out of the exchange being actionable
flag and most likely it's just
meaningful black so that that was
basically initial suggestion but this is
that's why it doesn't work
alright let's go of the next one the
next one will be something like like
this
let me just clear the board
I'm still a little bit debating whether
to which one to put I think I'll put
this one all right look here look here
Queen on age five pounds a free Shi free
G to H freaking on each one
pawns the 5 is 6 g 7 h 7 Queen D 3 rooks
e 8 and B 1 kinked on g8 and it's white
to move this position white to move
probably a little bit easier than others
than the previous one but still let's
see how you guys do it
okay but but like oh I would like the
entire line if you guys calculate this I
would like the entire line because you
know it's easy to throw and move the
group g7 or okay evade or any move or
whatever but like it's different when
you have to actually decide if you play
a game you need to basically calculate
so para la posada it could be Ruby g7
but I just need you to say the entire
line till till it the end basically or
until it let's say it's clear because
you know
if this one requires those of precision
so this small hinder could requires lots
of precision so I will not accept
solutions like rook to a g7 that's it
this requires lots of precision here and
considering how good you guys are you
guys can do it I believe and if you
can't then don't be the first one that I
taught you that you couldn't if you
struggle I will show you the solution I
will go to the maybe easier one OK ROCK
day is just 17 to 7 rook f7 what no
Queen have some you mean King go h6 okay
King okay first of all terminal the
problem the rational function test as
well after Queen f6 do I have to walking
H Phi 2 I have maybe something else
because it will be too easy to kind of
like I wouldn't be too easy for a puzzle
to jazz you know after Queen f6 King h5
to g4 mate do you guys think that it
would be so easy it's not so easy
anymore
the first panel will were so easy but
like right now is getting a little bit
more difficult so what's the problem
with Queen f6 what can i play
with black
because yes it is Route 87 that that's
true but they are utilizing to calculate
because there are a lot of traps on the
way
yep Queen f6 queen g6 yes exactly
and black is fine because been probably
you have to take on f3 6 and then root x
b1 and this is basically
basically it's some draw hunt game let's
say maybe CY has sometimes but should be
drawn with correctly in the first
position f7 to f3 of lot of frets and
then I met theta the father fingers were
after Luke takes a free that I can play
rook takes f1 for instance with check
and I'm getting my first faster but
coming back to this line with yes
rook texture 17 texture 7 Queen f7 King
h6 and Queen f6 is Queen b6 therefore we
go Queen a for Queen a4 and and what
next what happens next because pinafores
correct
let's take after Queen afore I go king
h5 let's say
because is it over already order still
some of to be played
okay there are so many things that are
going on let me read
okay but the thing is a long ago King g7
but I go King age five
rational function test after King H four
okay
King h5g for King H for Queen f2 I need
to play King g5 but first and foremost I
need to play King g5 I have other moves
like Queen G free for instance is one of
a second move I think I have a skink
taste h3 which after which I don't
really see anything for for white but
okay you know guys maybe I will just
maybe put the ball ready put it on the
board because we will be maybe easier
for people who don't follow up with this
sort of Tatarstan we are talking about
king days g7 Queen f7 King h6 Queen f4
because Queen f6 is queen g6 Queen f6
doesn't work because of Queen g6 is
always that initially so Queen a4 is
very important move and right now we are
discussing King h5 and this is the
position whether we are talking about
right now
engage 5g for king h4 queen f2 is not a
mate
I said I have different moves in mind
impossible
a quickie inch for Queen f6 again then a
king queen f6 and I can play and all
kinte's h3 was the parameter don't
forget you are pinned on the first rank
yes g4 King g6 Queen Isis is made that's
true but like after g4 I definitely go
king gage for you know guys there is
something called a group candidate moves
and in this position you are only
considering just one move in this
position g4 do you I have maybe some
other possibilities
terminal no your surgeon is not correct
oh wait wait wait
terminal yeah oh okay I didn't miss your
miss your message
yeah king h5 queen g4s you're right
Queen g4 yes yes queen g4 yeah I did
sorry I'm mister mister come on Quincy
for King H this Queen h4 Kim sent Queen
f6 yes that's the solution that's true
yes o queen g4 here is the move because
g4 is a mistake simply because King
gauge for and Queen f6 and for instance
I can even take here I don't see any
problem with that because you never can
go rogue f3 Hinduja freed also you can
go but I grew up free then it's
impossible because it's pin on the first
rank so Queen h6 let's say or something
I don't know King to xg4 and like life
simply wins just cause all the ponds
endures at the best maybe some perpetual
if white can find but I don't think so
but here Queen g4 is the solution King
gauge signal terminal said like here and
if King g6 there is Queen f6 King h5 g
for mate and after queen of King g7
Queen f7 Queen f6 King create Queen f7
King h8 Queenie 8 and she's just mating
attack this is just winning because
there's this for instance okay this is
mate not here sorry
unified mate and if King Queen h6
basically you just can be even this it
now Queen g6 is not good enough anymore
well I mean anything wins already so
bets with the idea I was to find Queen a
for any Queen g4 here because this was
very tricky so
yeah this for this was true I think we
read it was really nice one okay let's
go over the next one the next one will
be
actually there will be this one
okay this won't be very simple as I was
trying to recover cousin the Booga just
comes like remember one puzzle that I
had in mind and I wanted to quickly
recall how it go I was I was about the
position so let's do this would be a
little bit easier because they would've
whatever to harder ones so let's do
right now a little bit easier one here
here
here
all right way to play
yes patella Posada you had in different
line yeah but that's the thing that
there are better you know the Ruffner
bum no more kind of like bird if there's
always some not all but something
there's better defense that you what you
calculate is that the entire point you
need to basically try to find you know
best the best option for your opponent
as well when you calculate because not
go for that yeah for the easiest let's
say what you can calculate yourself and
so on so yeah this is 96 yeah this I was
just to recall like just because I
recall this position and I really like
it so I just went to show 96 this was
very simple one but like anyway just
went to because it like I I remembered
it so I just went to show it if they see
the net five mate obviously and if Queen
must some world and basically 97 it's
very nice very nice puzzle I really like
kind of like this position so I wanted
to show it because I recall it was very
simple one let's do it right now
maybe something also a little bit easier
because your guys actually now know they
will not be let's see how you guys doing
how you guys will do it this one or this
one
[Music]
yes okay let's go with with this one
would be like not so easy but not so
difficult
I think well we will see
okay black b56 pons pons if for h5g
seven of seven night on c4 Queen on d5
rock on eight to King on g8 and white
pawns before the five before before if
free F to G to H three King on f1 and
Bishop on e one rook c1 and Quincy free
and black to play plan to the position
yes is about this position so it's black
to play
yeah
yeah it was theoretical line that I
looked at like 2012 I think and I kind
of like really got imprinted in my
memory so alright so this position and
black to play
so what do you guys think about this one
why black to play and how black can put
some pressure more like that
all right rational function test you're
too good okay free taxi free yes that's
the solution
yes Lazcano yes ruisrock a free yes and
the idea is on the fork
I think idea that works here for white
is basically this fork for black I mean
route 83 and right now you know we just
take the pond and white cannot take
because just 93 follows and that's it so
yeah this is the solution and I'm not
another one
the thicker guys do this one because
it's very sneaky position it's clear it
I got a lot of puzzles the 395 Bishop f1
King g1 a king you wanna mean rook each
one okay one Queen D one black a 7 p 7c
7d v f7 g 6h 6 night only 7 King Khan f8
rook on a 8 a night raid Bishop on g7 C
8 and queen on d8 and wide to play why
to move
yep in paragraph three rock to rock
rocky thanks you for yes
what about this one
yep again this is true Knight b6 yep
that's true Knight b6 and yeah there's
the idea it takes b6q I mean like quindi
one would you wanna take some b6 rook b8
mate yes that's the thing and probably
in my opinion 96 yes guide that's true
and after my b6 the blacks best move is
just Bishop e6 and just give the
exchange and try to survive this somehow
but nevertheless is the what black is
supposed to do here either way like okay
so what was that was just basic Knight
b6 yeah this is the solution and this is
game actually a voltaic 'vine took from
2016
so in repeating big I think or something
like this and I think we should be six
the best move for Bishop g4 but I just
give the exchange here and try to save
this somehow
but you know no matter was just exchange
done like it's Jesus you know I mean
what is just winning here so I think
I'll do give you guys I will give you
guys one more puzzle and it will be it
for today so it will be this position
Kingdom g1 Queen takes Queen 93 pawns
it's very entertaining puzzle so I hope
you guys you guys will like it
and again I'd the entire line not just
like move or two moves just entire line
then I test yes it's what to move so
here why to move
so what do you guys think about this one
is the last puzzle for today so let's
see if we can solve it you should
because not so difficult but like it's
very entertaining and requires also a
little bit of precision so let's see how
you guys are doing it
okay rational test function the
terminals say the same line rook is six
fold by Queen g6 yes this is one of the
ideas but first we need to take on h6
this is what terminal and the Russian
fighters were saying so be sure HC is
that the right move here
so basically but there is one thing that
I'm gonna be concerned about
we should we shoot x86 code checks on h6
root I see six days on e6 or Queen g6
King JJ Qin h6 kingi 826 King h8 9 g5
rook f1 king of one I should know this
sounds right I was just thinking that
maybe I misread it because I thought
what you were saying term with rational
function test that you were saying here
because it's the solution yes takes
takes rook e6 very nice tech wing g6
here and I was thinking for a second
that you were saying here Knight g5 but
I just misread in the chat sorry about
that
because here is this is not good because
here back at like Ice Queen 7 and
suddenly black is okay but the thing
that was correct and would you what do
you actually sell in the Chinese Queen
g6 here King JJ and 9 IG 5 and yes group
text f1 king of one wins 97 next and
queen e7 for instance the knight of
seven as well for instance also
regression probably wins yeah
both wind so yeah this is the and this
is the solution and basically just has
to give the Queen and drop quintet of
science is just winning yeah but the
thing is also the last thing I want to
mention with this and in this position
after Queen H Queen g6 King h8 you need
to take 4 on h6 first because 9 g5 is
not possible and you need to maintain
this point h6 in order to get the square
for G on g5 for the night to launch you
know to kind of like add it to the
attack and but now first we need to give
play Queen g6 and the 95 here and this
is the correct solution and this is what
terminal says
so very nice very nice Paolo this was
game actually Paulo Mario vangu I in
actually blitz so it's really impressive
that you know like you know in this he
played it but anyway it was pretty nice
and also simple relatively so thank you
guys and I'm doing it for me for today
and I guess I'll see you next time thank
you for wishing me good I universe
championships
hopefully it wouldn't be postponed will
be okay and hopefully everything stays
okay there is a situation all right
thank you and until next time bye